with Europe's migration crisis simmering
long-term solutions still absent spare a
thought for the world's developing
nations which hosts the lion's share of
millions of migrants and refugees more
than eighty-five percent of the total
countries have hosted huge numbers of
refugees for long periods even decades
countries like Ethiopia Pakistan Sudan
miss Abu zayeed was at a joint session
of parliament development and foreign
affairs committees ahead of the big UN
summit on movements of refugees and
migrants solidarity between nations
burden sharing and good integration and
resettlement policies are key to better
management she said that and a mental
switch to see migrants as a benefit
communities not a burden no country can
do this alone no matter how big or how
rich or so ever you're having this
massive number of people coming all at
once even as the smallest country can
help with a few things like some jobs
some scholarships helping people learn
their language so they can integrate
them how and we included and not be a
problem all the more relevant in light
of more frequent and more catastrophic
weather changes NOS falta probablemente
ser más efficacies sobre todo el dia
logo con los paises tercero mientras no
una solución a problemas que el cambio
climatic o genera M muchisimas partes
del mundo tu an sama takes place in New
York on sep tember the 19th with leaders
of more than 190 countries taking part
you